Thank you.
Thank you. No, thank you.
Well, Secretary Clinton, welcome back
to Google. It's great to be here. Eric,
thank you. Grown a little bit
since I've been here. Last
just a little,
are you talking about my weight?
I knew I gained some pounds here.
No,
the company is much larger
and even more successful.
And thank you for your first visit.
We're here to talk about your book, um,
which you know, I've actually read.
Thank you. I did want to present you,
I did want to present you
with my book and I won.
It's entitled how Google Works and I
want you to notice something that's
different between your book and my book.
Now your book,
your book is 600 pages in very,
uh, lots of, lots of words.
My book is 37 pages and it uses big type
and my book has black and white photos
and yours has color photos.
So on a pound for pound basis,
my book is more valuable.
Well,
but there are many things you can do
with my book that you can't do with this
book such as well you can work out. So
you know, you can work out with my book,
you can work out with your boss,
a lovely and,
and if you get two copies you'll be
balanced while you're working out.
You can use it as a doorstop.
This would just wipe under the door.
Imagine using that as a doorstop. So
I don't know. I think it's kind of
a Justin draw,
don't you think?
Well at some point we're going
to be talking about book,
but I want you to notice that my book,
my book is so short,
you can read it during this interview.
Well I have to say there is a particularly
attractive picture of you on page 31
wearing some kind of ridiculous hat,
um,
with some model of an airplane and
a picture of Bill Gates in the back.
Let's get to work.
So Secretary Clinton,
your book is entitled hard choices.
And what we're going to do is
when I have some questions, Jimmy,
we have some dory questions
that is submitted from the
audience and we have some
live questions as well. And, um,
the first one is want to ask you is
that you and I had a very dear friend,
Richard Holbrook who died unexpectedly
of a heart attack and you had appointed
him to do the negotiation and Afghanistan.
Do you think that his death affected the
outcome and Afghanistan as a brilliant
negotiator?
Did we miss him that much?
Did we end up in roughly the right place
in Afghanistan at the end of it all?
There's two parts to that
question. Let me address. Um,
our friend Richard Holbrooke.
First he was in my view, uh,
the premier diplomat of our generation.
He was dramatic when called for,
he was persistent,
he was tough minded,
but he believed passionately that you
couldn't end a war if you didn't talk to
the people on the other side. Now
that may sound simplistic, but indeed,
that's a huge obstacle for
many in diplomacy, politics,
governments to get over.
How do you end a war? Uh,
if you talk to the people you despise,
who you view as the troublemakers,
the instigators and Richard came at a,
the assignment I asked him to take on
behalf of the president and myself, uh,
with that strong conviction born
out of as many years of experience.
And in particular his ending
of the wars in the Balkans.
When my husband was president,
he spent a lot of time with Milosevic,
a most unsavory character.
He drank with him.
He yelled at him,
he bullied him,
he listened to him and eventually was
able to get to the date and peace accords,
which ended the war even though it didn't
end all of the political and ethnic
and other problems that are unfortunately,
I'm still prevalent.
When I asked him to take on the
task in Afghanistan and Pakistan,
he went at it with his same level
of commitment, even relish. Uh,
and as I write in the book,
we were beginning a process of,
uh,
reaching out to and responding
to outreach from the Taliban.
And I gave a speech that tried to make
the case that that might be distasteful.
It certainly was to me for many reasons
as to how they treat people in general
and women in particular.
But there had to be a political
negotiation in order to
try to end the conflict.
And literally the day he died, uh, in, uh,
was he ha he suffered a terrible,
um,
attack in my office.
We were talking about the first meeting
that we had engineered between a,
an American diplomat, one of
Richard's lieutenants, uh, and, uh,
a representative of Moolah Omar.
I guess the short answer, Eric,
is that Richard would never
take no for an answer.
We had a lot of difficulties both with
President Karzai because he didn't want
us talking to the Taliban and we had
problems with the Taliban because they
didn't want to talk to President Karzai.
So we were playing a kind of multilevel
chess game and trying to move the
parties closer to talking to each
other. Uh, and unfortunately, uh,
with Richard's death,
we kept up the initiative,
but we didn't have that same overpowering
presence that he brought to it now
where we are with Afghanistan and
Pakistan because we looked at them,
uh, very much as presenting
similar challenges, uh,
to a lasting, uh, and to threats
first of all to the region.
And even beyond, uh, is, uh, a,
an election that was held, uh,
that has been criticized for
irregularities that now finally,
and I give an secretary
Kerry credit for going there,
there's no substitute for going to
these places and staying and trying to
engineer some kind of solution that there
will now be a total audit of all the
votes in Afghanistan to determine
who the next president is.
And things are kind of on
hold until we know that. Uh,
what I think of as the three
biggest challenges is number one,
getting a new president in who
could keep Afghanistan unified. Uh,
despite all of the problems that
many of us had with President Karzai,
that was his primary goal,
to try to keep the country
unified and not fly off, uh,
in different ethnic directions.
Um,
and we need to support whoever that next
president is and do our best to give
him the authority that he needs to try
to keep the country unified. Secondly,
continuing to work with the
Afghan security forces, uh,
they have proven to be much
more dependable, effective, uh,
fighters,
uh,
taking the fight to the Taliban because
the Taliban is very clear that they
intend to reoccupied territory.
They lost to a coalition troops in the
last several years following the surge
that President Obama ordered a,
so continuing to work and support the
Afghan security forces and then finally
being well aware that so many of the
problems in Afghanistan are incubated in
Pakistan and the Pakistani government
is now facing some of the most serious
threats that it historically has.
Because as I say in the book,
they had an idea that was never going
to be workable for the longterm,
which is you can keep poisonous snakes
in your backyard and expect them only to
bite your neighbors.
And the Pakistani military
and intelligence establishment
have unfortunately
over years, uh, worked with supported, uh,
lots of the terrorist groups,
extremist groups for their own purposes,
some of which was to keep
Afghanistan, uh, kind of off kilter.
So there has to be a lot of, uh, effort
made to work with the Pakistanis,
as difficult as that is.
And that's something that I spent some
time on in the book because I worked very
hard to try to have as I'm effective,
a relationship as we could.
But at the end of the day,
the Pakistanis have to stand
up to the threat from within,
which is also a threat to, uh,
Afghanistan. And by the way,
a continuing threat to India.
So it's a, we've made progress,
but not nearly enough.
I was in fact seen a little bit after you
were an I sounded incredibly confusing
to figure out is that while I was there,
the President I met with was
gotten rid of by the supreme court over
something involving financial and this
child and his child. Um, in the book
you spent a fair amount of time on,
I think one of the significant foreign
policy achievements during your tenure
involving the pivot to Asia. Right?
And when I lay it out, right,
we've got the Pec San problems.
You were the first person to really open
up Burma, Myanmar met with an sung g, g,
et cetera. Um, but you start looking
at like the is an example of the,
that the Spratly islands and
this line called line nine, nine,
I in Japan and the others, it's
getting more confusing to an outsider.
You talk about the pivot.
Do you think that we understand
how to navigate now between these,
each of these countries is becoming more
nationalistic as it becomes stronger?
Right. Well, that is a trend that, um, uh,
I saw really beginning to take off and
it has a number of implications both for
the region, uh, but also for us
and the rest of the world. Um,
as China has gotten much
more economically powerful,
it's understandable that they,
um, want to project their power,
uh, but it's, uh, quite a threatening
to the rest of the region.
And what I saw as a,
uh,
a growing threat was the increasing a
budgetary resources going to the People's
Liberation Army,
uh,
to build up their naval capacity so
that they could project power, uh,
on the seas. Now the United States, uh,
primarily has kept the peace, uh, in, uh,
Asia on in navigable waters,
uh,
for the protection of commerce.
And our navy has been
a very positive force,
but it's clear to me that the Chinese
intend to challenge a American naval
superiority. That's their
perfect right to do. So.
There they are a sovereign country.
They get to make those decisions.
But the problems that Eric alluded to
are having a rebound effect around the
region so that if you see China developing
its first aircraft carrier with plans
for a number of more carriers,
and you see China being quite
aggressive on territorial claims,
not that they're willing
to arbitrate those claims,
but they're merely asserting them against
the Philippines and Vietnam and Japan
primarily. Now, um,
and you see that this could lead to
increasing tension and maybe even conflict
in the region. Then we have, uh,
an opportunity but also a responsibility
to work closely with number one,
our allies because we have neutral
defense treaties with five nations in the
region. Obviously Japan and South
Korea and the Philippines, Australia,
but also Thailand.
So we our treaty bound to
work with and if necessary,
protect our allies.
Nobody wants to see any kind
of conflict that erupts.
Uh,
but when you look at what's happening
between China and Vietnam and China and
Japan and China and the Philippines,
this is going to take some
very careful management.
And so it's takes a combination of
America continuing to assert itself as a
Pacific power but intensive diplomacy
to try to send the message to China.
Why would you want to
disrupt 40% of global trade?
Why would you want to skirt the
edges of potential conflict?
And you see what it's happening in Japan.
Japan is getting much more nationalistic
and aggressive in response to that.
So this is going to be a
primary obligation and area
of concern for the United
States going forward.
It's very important that China is
ultimately does not become China.
And the people who are opposed to China,
yes,
you could set up for another hundred
years, some sort of, uh, uh, of a,
of a real contest. Well, you
know, one of the things, and I,
and I write about this because I
became aware, you know, China had,
when I became secretary of state to
issues that they repeatedly stressed as
their core interests,
Tibet and Taiwan. I mean,
that was every time you met with a
Chinese official what you would hear in
addition to everything else. And
you know, they were confused. Um,
by our support for the Tibetans
are openness to the Dalai Lama.
I had a,
uh,
a really vigorous disagreement with Jiang
men who was present at the end of the
nineties over Tibet because I kept
saying, China's a great country. I mean,
you're growing at 10 plus
percent at though in those years.
Why are you so obsessed with Tibet?
And he said,
why are you so obsessed with Tibet?
And we had this big back and forth,
and I said,
my goodness,
somebody meets with the Dalai Lama
and you want to write them out of the,
you know,
the global order practically.
But it's very deeply felt by the
Chinese and on Taiwan, obviously,
you all know starting in 2010 I'm in
one of these very long meetings that are
made longer because you have to have
consecutive translation in many of them.
Some of you have done business on behalf
of Google in China, you know that.
And all of a sudden it was Tibet,
Taiwan, and the South China Sea.
And I just sat up straight and I thought,
what do you mean the South China Sea?
So I began to engage with my counterparts.
I heard you mentioned the south China
Sea. What did you mean? Oh, what? Well,
what we meant was of course that we claim
the south China Sea. I said all of it.
I mean, this enormous body of water.
Absolutely it is China's. And then,
you know,
they began telling me why it was China
as they found pottery shards on this or
this a toll or this rocky reef
that went back to the Ming Dynasty,
therefore was China. I said,
really? Now let me, let me say this,
the United States.
And I asked him,
I actually had a map drawn up where
the United States claimed the entire
Pacific. And I said, look,
you know, you are our ally,
but you couldn't have beaten
the Japanese back and,
and you couldn't have had the kind of
economic rise without American power.
And we have, you know, we have
camp old cans of food everywhere.
You may have pottery shards,
but we've left our debris too.
And so we're claiming the entire Pacific.
I said, this is an absurd argument.
Oh No. Very serious. And not only that,
we're climbing the east China Sea and
we're going after this and Kakuma,
which the Japanese have a claimed that
we're going after the territorial waters
of Vietnam because obviously they want
to drill to see what might be off their
coast.
This was a very well thought out
introduction of a third core interest.
And therefore we have to take it
very seriously. And what I've argued,
and I made this very clear
to our Chinese friends,
the United States doesn't take positions
on these islands and who should govern
them or who they belong to,
but where there are disputes,
we have dispute resolution mechanisms
that China as a great nation should be
part of taking advantage of.
And so this is going to be an ongoing
debate between us and within the region.
So
is it to show you how good this book is,
there's a lengthy conversation
about the origins of this and um,
the secretary talks about the original
hide and bide strategy that a Dung Dung
Dung chicken had and how much has changed.
Do you also spend a fair amount of time
talking about a genuine hero in the
world, uh, Ang century cheap, right?
And you describe her as there
was a quiet dignity about her,
the coiled intensity of a vibrant mind
inside of a long imprisoned to body,
right? They sort of glimpses
of the way you started,
I found absolutely fascinating. I'd like
to move to an area where you know, you,
you say hard choices.
I personally see no choices and that's
Syria and you're famously known for
having been, or at least allegedly
being in favor of earlier intervention.
And I just want to review
where we are now. Um,
170,000 deaths,
a 11 and a half million internally
dislocated people, 3 million refugees,
one out of six people in Lebanon,
one out of five people in
Jordan are now refugees.
Imagine if that happened from Canada
and Mexico to the United States.
The impact on the economy. Uh,
and if that's not bad enough,
it's the biggest humanitarian
conflict in the world today.
There's obvious groups to support fi
it's a proxy war involving Russia,
Iran, Syria, et cetera.
And now the latest is of
course this isis group,
which should manage to get to some
number of miles to Baghdad. Um,
it's not, not clear what to do, you
know, do you do a no fly zone? Well,
who do you protect, right? If you're
an arm, somebody who are going to arm.
When you think about it,
had we followed what you wanted to do,
what would we have done and what
should we do now or what can we do now?
You talk about this in the book,
but obviously you don't talk about the
current isis situation. It's uh, it's,
I think it's the biggest current problem
in the world in terms of just mass
death and problems.
Well, Eric, I label that, um,
chapter a wicked problem, uh,
which is, uh, yeah, futurist concept, uh,
because there really
weren't any, uh, clear, uh,
decisions with a straight
line to consequences.
Even if you made account
for unintended consequences,
it was always going to be a hard choice.
What I argued back at the beginning
of the conflict was that in,
uh,
looking at Assad's crackdown
and his alliances with Iran,
uh, Russia and Iran is
proxy Hezbollah in Lebanon.
There would be a very
serious, uh, issue. Uh,
somebody needs some help back
there. Can we, can we help?
How about some water?
There's somebody pass out.
Yeah. Okay. I think we're fine. We got
somebody back there to help. Okay, let's,
let's continue. Okay.
Um, if you looked at the,
the,
um,
level of violence that Assad was willing
to use and I was pretty sure from the
beginning he would do whatever it took
to beat back the demonstrators and to
hold on to territory. His father had done
it before him. Some of you might recall,
um,
in leveling the city of Hama,
which had been a hotbed of opposition
and a particular home for Muslim
Brotherhood opponents to the prior
regime. So I had no doubt, in fact,
one of the stories I tell in the book,
I asked the Foreign
Minister of Saudi Arabia,
so Al Faisal,
who had been in that
position for many years, um,
whether he thought there was any way to
change the calculation of a Assad and
have him either,
uh,
began to tamp down the violence or look
for a political settlement and no sewed,
said no because his mother
would never let him. Uh,
and that I thought was very telling
that there was this family obligation in
forced by his mother who
would say to him every day,
here's what your father would have done.
So given that lineup of
character's history in the,
like,
I believe that if we had gone in to
identify and properly vet members of the
original opposition, which were
not al Qaeda, we're not isis,
they may have been a pharmacists or
doctors or lawyers or students before the
opposition,
a rose up against Assad's brutal crackdown
that we would get to know who the
likely hard men on the other side were.
And perhaps we could help to build from
that a viable opposition force that
could hold ground against
Assad. And at the same time, uh,
be the anchor for developing a
more effective political arm.
You know, I could sit here
today and say I was right,
but I can't say that because we don't
know what would have happened had we
followed that particular approach.
There were very good
arguments on the other side.
But what I know now is that what I worried
about has happened that Assad has not
moderated his behavior.
The only good thing that has come out of
the last two years is the removal of at
least the known stockpiles of
chemical and biological weapons,
which I do think was a, an
important, uh, accomplishment.
But we know that territory is
being taken by extremist groups.
Isis being the most audacious,
uh,
with their claim of a caliphate that
crosses the border between Syria and Iraq.
And I think we have a pretty
good idea what that would mean,
what that would mean for the region,
uh,
where you could possibly
have a very extreme, uh,
organized territory.
Uh,
that was a safe haven and a launching
ground. We saw this in Afghanistan.
I mean,
that's what happened in the border areas
when al Qaeda decided to ally itself
with the Taliban and set up shop there.
And it doesn't necessarily
mean just misery for Sunni's,
uh,
who are not of their extreme
nature and others within Iraq.
And the same within Syria.
It can lead to problems in Europe
where we think at least 2000, uh,
Europeans, uh, with passports have gone
to fight, uh, with extremist groups.
And it certainly can mean a more
threats to us. So what to do now?
I think part of what we have to do is,
uh,
what we're trying to do and
that is to restabilize Iraq.
And the reason it's so difficult is that
Prime Minister Maliki basically reneged
on every commitment he made to the
United States as well as his own people.
Uh, when, uh, he was
legitimately elected, um,
he was able to form a government the
first time he was just reelected.
And the problem is that he began
governing in an exclusive sectarian way,
cutting the Sunni's out of power,
refusing to pay the Sunni fighters that
the United States had recruited to get
rid of al Qaeda in Iraq,
which was one of our major achievements
on behalf of the Rockies before we left.
And refusing to have a fair deal
over oil revenues with the Kurds,
the Kurds,
and a lot of the Sunni tribal leaders
are basically of the mind that you can't
trust Maliki. You can't, uh,
work with him and we're not going to
support him as he tries to take back
territory.
So it's a political negotiation that we
and others are engaged in because unless
you can get the local Sunni leaders once
again to throw their lot in on behalf
of a unified Iraq,
you cannot drive isis out of Mosul
and other places that it has seized.
This is very dangerous.
Well, they're, they're,
they're very dangerous.
There kind of a, a,
a follow on to the original al Qaeda,
but not as,
um, uh, based in, uh,
the leadership of a bin
Ladin Ans hour hearing.
It's now younger people, they're more
violent, they're more aggressive.
They're trying to do what
has been the dream of, uh,
extremist Sunni's, uh,
caught up in terrorism, uh,
for a number of years now. And that
is to establish, or in their mind,
reestablish Kayla,
uh,
Kayla fate and put one of
their own in charge. So, yeah,
they're very dangerous and they will
not be satisfied in just governing
territory.
They will believe it's their,
both their religious duty and their
desire for greater power that they have to
take this further a field.
So,
um, what I do is ask you a little bit
about the Israeli Palestinian situation.
I'd like to talk to you a little bit
about what you've been working on since
leaving office and,
uh,
and then we'll go to questions and we
have thousands of questions. Uh, it,
it in Google. So, um,
in the book you talk at some length about
negotiating and getting to know Bibi
Netanyahu, um, charismatic leader by,
by any standard and the challenges he's
faced from the terrorism and of the book.
You talk a lot about Hezbollah and the
Lebanon war and those sorts of things.
Israel is today confronting, um, the Gaza,
the Gaza rockets, Hamas and
so forth. Looking at it,
I was just there who has
a big presence there. Um,
it's to some degree in Hamas has
interest to have this cycle continue.
They get money, they get resources,
they're getting rockets out of Syria,
et cetera. Um, and the rockets
can now reach the entire country.
And I was thinking about it,
if you think about, uh, our,
our good friends in Canada,
right?
So Imagine Canada was different
and somehow was raining
rockets on us or Mexico
or whatever, people here would
go crazy. Right? Right, right.
And so you can really understand,
in fact,
the Israelis have built
this thing called Iron Dome,
which actually has intercepted
80 or 90% of the rockets,
which is a remarkable technical
achievement and good for them.
Do you have a reading of what's going to
happen next because it doesn't seem to
be getting better?
Well, you know, you might've
seen the president, um, doing a,
a live press statement,
uh,
this morning from the White House and
he's asked a secretary Kerry to go to the
region to try to reestablish the November,
2012 cease fire that I negotiated back
at the time when rockets were raining,
uh, on Israel. And, uh,
I went from Cambodia to
Israel to negotiate what the
Israelis would accept and
then to go to Cairo to negotiate
with then president Morsi, um,
and we were able to reach,
uh,
a cease fire that held until this month.
And I'd make three points.
One Hamas really does have its back
against the wall and that's always
dangerous.
You know,
they were basically driven out of Damascus
because that's where they had taken
up their headquarters for years.
But when Assad consolidated the Alawite
a minority to go after the majority of
the population,
which are Sunni's,
it became impossible for Hamas to
maintain its headquarters there.
They moved to Cairo, uh,
because at the time, you know,
the Muslim Brotherhood candidate
Morsi was the president.
There was a lot of sympathy there.
Um,
and they began to try to,
uh,
maneuver to control splinter groups
within gossip because it's not just Tomas,
there are some even harder
core extremist groups, uh,
within Gaza.
So you have a couple of different
groups led by Hamas gathering up more
sophisticated weaponry. So when I
negotiated the cease fire with Morsi,
he had never done anything like that,
but he did have a
relationship, uh, with Hamas.
So we were able to come up with a written
agreement where Israel made certain
commitments,
Hamas made certain commitments.
And thankfully it was before
there was an invasion.
We were about 48 hours from an invasion.
So what has happened since,
well Morrissey's gone,
um, LCC is the president.
He basically has declared the Muslim
Brotherhood and everyone associated with
them, which would include Hamas,
are threats to the Egyptian state.
So ammas no longer has
a, in Cairo, uh, the, uh,
Westbank has remained fairly secure and
stable and part because of the attitudes
still in the West Bank that they'd
rather have a negotiation then go back to
resistance. So Hamas and it's, um,
allies who have really brought about the
importation of more long range rockets,
um,
has for whatever combination of
calculations decided that it's in their
interest, as Eric said, to
once again attack Israel. Uh,
maybe because they believe
they will get more support,
they will get more financial resources.
Uh,
maybe they think that they will cause
an uprising in the West Bank that would
join with them. They have a number of
different reasons why they might do this.
So once they began firing the rockets
and the rockets have longer range and
there's somewhat more accurate,
but the iron dome,
which the United States funded but
which is Israeli technology has worked
surprisingly well and intercepting 80,
90% of the rockets.
But there was also the increasing
threat from tunnels. You know,
it used to be that Hamas had tunnels
going into the Sinai and those were both
for smuggling weapons, but
also smuggling goods, uh,
that would escape the Israeli embargo.
The Egyptians have done a
much more thorough job of
shutting those tunnels down,
but,
uh,
Hamas has been busy building tunnels
into Israel with the primary purpose of
attacking Israelis and trying to spark a,
a very violent response.
I can't believe that the current Hamas
leadership did not know that if they kept
up their attacks, Netanyahu
would be forced to respond. Uh,
as I said, when I got to Jerusalem for
the first part of the negotiations,
they were already sending
out notices, uh, for, uh,
reserve soldiers to begin mustering
up and that they were going to have to
invade.
So I believe that Hamas wanted
to provoke this reaction.
Uh, and I believe that Netanyahu,
at the end of the day, uh,
the Canadian Mexican example is, you know,
not so far fetched. I mean, any country,
your first obligation is to protect your
citizens. And I believe Netanyahu, um,
knew that he had to take action and
he has an Israel has the right to self
defense.
So now we're into a not
only a very unfortunate,
um, clash, but a propaganda
war. Uh, you know, the terrible,
horrible pictures of
children, uh, who are, uh,
the victims of Israeli military action,
uh,
which is re Israel is right
to say is in large measure,
not completely,
but in large measure because of the way
Hamas has cited it's rockets and set up.
It's operating centers in neighborhoods
surrounded by civilians in houses.
Uh, the tunnels where there
was a firefight with Hamas,
a fighters coming out of one
of the tunnels and Israeli
soldiers to Americans do,
you know, dual citizens to young American
men serving in the IDF, uh, killed.
So we have to try,
if we can,
to negotiate another ceasefire.
I've Egypt declared a ceasefire.
Israel accepted it.
Hamas rejected it in part because I do
think they want to provoke what we're now
seeing and it's deeply distressing.
But unfortunately,
unless there's a mutual cease fire,
I think Israel will continue
with their military objectives,
which are defined and destroy the tunnels,
find and destroy as many of
the rockets as they can. Uh,
and there will continue to
be a terrible loss of life.
I agree. And it's very sad. The,
let's make a context switch.
Um,
since you left office,
you've spent a great deal of time
on empowerment, entrepreneurship,
the role of women and children.
Uh,
Google has partnered with
you a little bit on that. Um,
and I think people will be interested in
what do you think needs to be done? You've
given a series of speeches about this,
the role of women and so forth. Uh,
you're obviously committed to a tech.
Take us through your thinking.
Well, I, I do want to thank Google and
being one of our partners in this effort.
Uh,
when I got out of the State Department,
I joined my husband and my
daughter at the Clinton Foundation.
My husband had started it and
I'm very proud of what he built.
I had nothing to do with it.
I was in the Senate and in the
State Department for those 12 years,
but he came up with the OnApproach that
I think is fairly called entrepreneurial
philanthropy, where you
bring people together, uh,
through the foundation and through
the Clinton Global Initiative, uh,
to partner to solve problems.
And we have very clear metrics.
Are you making progress or not?
And if you're not, then we're not
going to keep doing what doesn't work.
And we're going to do
more of what does work.
And we think we're all in this together.
So both internationally and
domestically, uh, there's a,
a number of really important projects.
Bill has just left a Borneo where we're
doing one of our climate initiatives,
trying to save the rain
forest in Indonesia,
partnering with a number of
other governments and businesses.
So when I got out,
in addition to wanting to work on the
foundation priorities and CGI priorities,
I added three. I added something
we call too small to fail.
And that is um,
a programmed,
aimed at persuading a families to read,
talk and sing to their babies.
Because what we know is if you come,
if you're our daughter,
uh,
Chelsea or our new grandchild,
you are going to be talked to and read
two and sung to until probably you just
want us to go away.
Um,
and we're doing it both because it's great
to build relationships and connection,
but we now know from brain research,
it builds brains.
And when a child from a family,
like one of ours goes to kindergarten,
that child will have already heard 30
million more words than a child from a
poor family.
Now,
that does not mean the child from
the poor family is any less loved,
any less treasured,
but there's not the time or understanding
often so that parents know they can be
their child's first teachers.
So we are partnering with, uh,
the next generation foundation in San
Francisco and a number of other groups
like sesame street to get
this message out. Secondly,
we rolled out at the Clinton Global
Initiative America meeting in Denver, uh,
last month,
a program that is aimed at trying
to work with companies like Google.
We'd love to talk to
you about this, but, uh,
to create ladders of opportunity
for unemployed young people,
we have 6 million young people in America
between the ages of 18 and 24 who are
neither in school nor at work.
And that's terrible for them and
it's terrible for us in our economy.
And then finally I took with me
my commitment to women and girls,
their empowerment, uh,
their full participation.
And my jumping off point is the
speech that I gave in 1995 in Beijing,
uh,
which was intended to make it very clear,
a statement of the global priority that
a human rights are women's rights and
women's rights are human rights.
But accompanying that was a platform
for action signed by 189 countries about
what they would do to move toward
full participation of women and girls.
And we've made progress
but not nearly enough.
So we started a program called no
ceilings and it's got three purposes.
Number one,
we want to be able with Google's help
and others to get the best data possible
so that we understand where the
gaps are. We know, for example,
we've made tremendous progress in
getting girls into primary education,
not so good in secondary education.
So what are the gaps?
How do we describe that
and how do we visualize it?
So people who may not the experts or
advocates in this field can look and see
what the remaining business is.
I have a chapter called
unfinished business and it's
really about what more we
need to do.
Now there are big differences between
the developing world and the developed
world and developing world.
You know,
we still have some very
clear obstacles to overcome.
We still have countries that don't even
give birth certificates to girl babies
because they're just not
important enough to register.
So when we say to ourselves, well, how
many girls are in school and you know,
a significant percentage don't even have
birth certificates and there's not a
good census, how do we measure
that? Or when we look at Asia,
there are 3 million fewer girls and
women than there are boys and men because
they just don't,
they're not born or they don't live to
their fifth birthday or they are victims
of violence and neglect.
And we have this huge gap.
And I think one of the problems that
China and India are facing and will face
even more is the big gap between
marriageable men and marriageable women.
And some of the violence against women
is a result of what is a very big
imbalance. Now in the so
called developed world, um,
we've changed our laws, but what
we have left our cultural problems.
And so in addition to getting the data,
where are the gaps,
we want to look at what are the solutions
and they will vary from country to
country,
region to region.
One of the efforts I made in the State
Department was to do an began to do with
the IMF,
the World Bank and others,
an economic analysis of what
it means for girls and women,
uh,
to be left out of economies.
Now we know girls and women
are in the informal economy,
but that's not counted in GDP.
I remember going to Africa in the
90s and all I saw were women working.
They were carrying water,
they were carrying firewood,
they were tending fields,
they were, you know, in the marketplaces.
And I asked an economist, I said,
how do you take account of all this
economic activity? And they said,
we don't get this in the informal economy.
So what I wanted was an analysis about
what difference it would make if we had
girls and women in the formal economy.
And it makes a huge GDP difference.
And the person in the,
in the world who has jumped on this more
than anybody is Prime Minister Abi of
Japan because when he took office,
he took office on the promise.
He was going to get the economy going
and he looked at trade barriers.
He looked at the lack of immigration,
but one of the biggest problems was
educated Japanese women were not in the
economy and that in fact,
if they had greater participation,
the projection was the Japanese
economy could go up to GDP.
[inaudible] economy is to use the talents
you already have, the talent you have
and raise the talent base of women
and girls in places where they're not
educated and take advantage of those
talents in places where they are.
It seems so obvious. Why
don't we just do it? Ah, yeah.
I want to try to figure out and with
Google's help we get the best analysis to
make the recommendation.
I really agree with.
I want to finish up with a book
with the last, the last paragraph.
You talk about the memorial service for
your mom passed recently and you said,
I looked at Chelsea and I
thought how much, how proud mom,
your mom was of her mom,
measured her own life by how much she
was able to help us and serve others.
I knew that if she was still with us,
she would be urging us to do the same.
Never rest on your laurels.
Never quit.
Never stopped working to make
the world a better place.
That's our unfinished business.
Is that why you work so hard?
It really is. Um, I don't want to
get all of psychobabble Lee, but, um,
it's okay. Uh, you know, uh,
I so admire my mother,
um,
because she had a miserable
childhood. I mean, just horrible,
abused, neglected, abandoned, um,
sent by herself at the
age of, you know, seven,
eight in charge of her younger
sister who was about six,
pulled on a train by
themselves in Chicago,
sent to California to live
with her paternal grandparents
who did not want her.
And, um, just a terrible experience.
And finally having to leave that home
at the age of 13 to get a job, uh,
working in another family's home,
taking care of their children and return
for room and board and the opportunity
if she could get her chores done
in the morning to go to school,
if she could get back, uh, in the
afternoon. So, I mean, when I was a child,
I didn't know any of this about my mother.
I just knew that she was a great mom
and she was fun and she, you know,
took wonderful care of us. But as
I learned more about her life, uh,
upon becoming a teenager
and a young adult,
I was just astonished because I thought,
you know,
so many things could have gone
wrong. I mean, she could've given up.
She could've been embittered.
She could, could've,
even if she'd gotten
married and have children,
she could have been as mean spirited
or neglectful as her mother and her
grandmother were to her.
But instead,
she works so hard to be a better person
and she never got to go to college.
But she was always studying and trying
to learn and believed passionately in
education.
And I think it did have a lot
to do with my sense of service,
uh,
because you know,
I remember going to Babysit for the
children of migrant farm workers, um,
who in Chicago, you know, they would come
up from Mexico and they'd pick crops,
they'd go through Illinois
that go into Michigan.
And our church had a babysitting program
for the youngest children on Saturday
morning so that the school age children
who went to school with us would be able
to go out into the fields.
And so I remember babysitting these
adorable little kids and my mother, um,
learning that one of the little girls
was going to have her first communion.
And of course I didn't have money for a
dress and my mother took the mother of
the little girl and you know,
bought a dress.
And My mother was always trying to
think of ways that just through her own
efforts she could help somebody else
and encouraging me to do the same.
So there's no doubt in my mind that
she was my biggest inspiration.
And her example, uh, was a, a great, uh,
continuing reminder of what can
happen because I'd end with this.
I asked her once, I said, with
all of your really suffering,
what made the difference, how did you turn
out the way you did? And she said to me
at so many points along the way,
somebody was kind to me.
It wasn't my family, but it was somebody
else. And she told me about, uh,
literally when she was like four years
old and her parents were teenagers,
totally irresponsible. They'd leave
her for days, they give her, you know,
a little bit of money and she'd have
to get herself down the stairs of the
tenement they lived in and go next door
to a restaurant and ask for food, uh,
with a little bit of money. And
she said, looking back to that,
I know they gave me more food than I could
pay for or when she was in school and
she would never have any lunch and
never had any money to buy lunch.
And the teacher noticed it. So the
teacher without embarrassing her, uh,
would bring an extra piece of fruit,
would bring an extra carton of milk and
would say, oh, I brought too much food.
Dorothy, would you like something?
Because I just can't eat all this. Again,
not humiliating her,
but making it possible for
her to receive that kindness.
And the family that she moved in to work
for was the first time she was ever in
an intact family that loved each other
and cared about each other and had plans
for the future.
And she could see all of that.
So it was just a great reminder when
you don't have to go into full time
philanthropy or charitable work
or faith based work or politics,
but there's always something
you can do that helps somebody.
And if you do it in a way that preserves
their dignity and gives them the
feeling that it was kindness
as opposed to arrogance,
it can make a huge difference. So I
think that, uh, left a great impression.
There isn't very nice picture of,
of you and your mom,
Chelsea and mark in the book. Yeah.
We have questions from the audience.
Let's get some folks lined up here.
Uh, but, uh, the overwhelming,
there's a ranking system that we use of
questioning and the overwhelming ranking
throughout the company. And this is
being watched all around the world.
And Google, um, he has a question
about the NSA and as you know,
Google is quite opposed along with the
other tech companies to what we see is
overreach by the NSA. Right.
And we all think, for example,
that bugging Angela Merkel's phone is,
you know, pretty stupid if I can be blunt.
Um,
what is your opinion of NSA's spying
surveillance, the domestic violence,
but this occurred I think
after you were there, right?
You have an opinion about this
number one question from Google.
Yeah. I mean, don't do stupid things. Um,
and that doesn't mean we don't need to
have a system of surveillance because we
do, I mean, I think
that has to be accepted,
but how we do it and how we explain
it and what we tell our partners is
incredibly important. I was just in
Berlin on my book tour in Europe,
and of course that was the number
one issue. And I, I said, look,
Angle Merkel is a friend of mine and
I apologize to her. It was wrong.
It shouldn't have been
Washington. You know, I had dinner
with her and she looked at me, he said,
what are they doing? Listening to my
conversations with my mother. Yeah,
I mean people will remember that.
Absolutely. And look, I think we were,
we were beginning to take a hard
look at what we did post nine 11.
Um,
and that was happening.
The president had actually
given a speech before, um,
the Snowden disclosures about the need
to take a hard look at the legislation
and how it was being implemented.
Um,
so we had to do that because I voted for
things and then I voted against things
trying to figure out how to get the
right balance in a security and liberty,
the age old question.
And we have to do,
we have to do a much better job and
we have to do it in a way that doesn't
affect our great companies like Google
because clearly that would be unfortunate
for us.
Let's go, uh, here, go ahead
for your first question and
then we'll go over here.
Sorry Clinton. Thank you
for joining us today. Um,
I want it to get your take on the state
of Congress and internal politics within
the US. It seems like things are getting
increasingly polarized to the point of
dysfunction. You know,
I think that the kick,
the can economic policies that we're
building is really hurting our country.
So I'm wondering what you think needs
to be done to fix it and who the right
people are to lead that effort.
Well, I think your question
is exactly on point. Um,
I think we have two crises
right now in our country.
We have an economic crisis that has to
do with both growth and inequality. Uh,
you may not feel it here at Google,
but it's real in the lives of,
of many Americans.
And we need to get back to doing smarter
things in terms of economic policies.
And we have a political crisis.
I would even argue it's a crisis of our
democracy because it's not functioning.
And I would make three
quick points. First, um,
having been in and around
politics for a long time. Um,
please don't get indifferent or disgusted
and walk away from it because truly
the best way of changing what's
going on is through voting.
I mean, that may sound simplistic,
but I've been there, I've seen it.
I know it can work and I would
have just a few pieces of advice.
Don't vote for anyone who says he or
she will never compromise. Um, and,
and does it proudly, you know,
they, they have all the answers.
They may even have a direct channel to
the divine so they know what should be
done. Uh, and therefore they're going to
Washington or they're going to Sacramento
wherever they're going.
And they will never compromise.
That is death to a democracy.
I don't know if any of you saw the Great
Steven Spielberg movie about Lincoln
and trying to get the
13th amendment passed.
There was just a great a movie I made
a great play in New York called all the
way about Lbj trying to
get civil rights past.
You've got to compromise if
you're going to make progress.
And so don't vote for people. Don't give
them money, don't encourage them. Uh,
you can be conservative,
but find people who understand the meeting
of conservative. It's not radicalism.
It's a conserving a and
trying to build on, uh,
institutions that work.
And then finally to go to your,
you're the final part of your question.
It's not only what citizens should do
in terms of voting and contributing and
trying to pick people who will be
better partners in solving our problems,
but it's what leaders
themselves have to do. Uh,
and Washington is now
set up for dysfunction.
People are elected often with the best
intentions and then they get there and
they spend all their money,
their time raising money so that they
can be reelected the next time instead of
doing the work that they were
elected to do the first time.
And they also are rarely with each other.
Uh,
it didn't use to be that way. You
met across the aisle, you met, uh,
across the ideological divide.
And we're not doing that,
so people don't get to know each other.
And so I think you,
if you are running for
one of these offices,
you just have to be absolutely committed
to spending a lot of time trying to
build relationships because at the end
of the day, that's what it's about.
You have to have enough trust,
enough understanding to be able
to make decisions and you know,
that's what we're missing right now.
I would also have, I have to bring
your book back and quote in general,
I was surprised at how many people in
Washington operated in an evidence free
zone where we're data and
science are disregarded.
You then go on and quote an unnamed senior
Bush administration official who I'm
dying to figure out who this is,
who said the reality based community.
People who believe that solutions
emerged from your judicious study of
discernible reality.
I've always thought that's exactly how
to solve problems the bush way when it
went on. That's not the way
the world really works anymore.
We're an empire now and when we act,
we create our own reality.
That attitude helps explain it a lot of
what went wrong during those years. So,
so maybe the answer is also,
let's, let's go back to the,
we can debate the principles and so forth,
but let's make sure the data's correct.
Correct.
Well, and what a place to talk about
this. I mean, that's exactly, I mean,
I used to give speeches about
being in an evidence free zone, uh,
in the Senate and we've got to figure
out a better way of breaking down the
intellectual barriers that exist between
people of different political beliefs.
There's some recent
research has been done,
and I would welcome any of your thoughts
on this that shows if you hold an
opinion strongly, like let's
just pick supply side economics,
trickle down economics, which don't
work. There's no evidence that it works,
but it is deeply believed by people,
um,
or the immigration is bad
for the United States.
Totally wrong evidence to the contrary
going, can we just pause for miles?
Isn't that amazing?
We just heard this.
No,
this country was built on immigration
hundred percent and, and so
we,
we know we have evidence,
but oftentimes it's difficult to break
through the psychological barriers to
hearing that.
So we've got to do a better job.
And I think about this a lot
because of the dysfunction.
Some people deny climate change because
they think they are doing it to protect
industries they make money from
or they get contributions from.
Some people deny it because they don't
understand the science and they kind of
just throw up their hands and it's easier
to say, oh well all workout. Some of it,
some people deny it for religious reasons,
whatever.
That's just one example of an issue
that we are gridlocked over and thank
goodness for President Obama beginning
to do things that will deal with climate
change, um, through executive action.
But how do we begin to have a conversation
again where we actually listened to
each other because the, you
know, we are much less sexist,
much less racist, much less homophobic
than we were a decade or two ago.
But boy,
the one remaining bias we have is we
don't want to be around people who share a
different political opinion. You know,
we just don't want to argue with them.
We don't want to listen to them.
And it's on both sides of the divide.
So we've got to do a better job of
question over here. Yeah, sorry.
Thank you Secretary Clinton.
Um, I was hoping we could, uh,
use some of your experience and dealing
with rather difficult international
crises and controversies with one of
the deep controversies affecting us.
What do you think it will take to
resolve the tension between advocates of
synchronous and asynchronous programming?
Ronnel's
um, all right. Are you,
are you saying, oh, would
you like to wow. Good.
Yeah. Well, I mean, I, I'm no expert,
but clearly no synchronous models
require lightweight threads.
Have you been, have you been
spending some time in Silicon Valley?
I've been thinking a lot
about silicon valley.
Did you actually have a real question?
Well, actually that was the right answer,
I guess, right? Yeah. Hey,
since we're so good at this,
I'm wondering if maybe I could
even ask you another one.
Given there,
there is a suggestion that increases in
productivity over the past few decades,
that the total number of jobs that
the American economy can even have,
maybe structurally less than the number
of people who are in need of jobs and
even more so for jobs that can actually
pay enough for someone to live on, right?
If this is really a
fundamental structural reality,
we're going to have to deal with
how do we adjust to such a world?
Well,
I I really glad you asked that because
I don't have a quick Glib answer to give
you,
but I can tell you that I would love
to have any thoughts from all of you
because you are making this new world.
I mean,
Google is a part of the future that
is out there. And as I look around,
you know, it's a very diverse crowd.
A lot of young and youngest people,
uh, who have, uh, uh, I think
they all look young. They do,
uh,
who,
who have skills and abilities that are
really required in this new future.
There is a serious political
and economic dimension to that.
And I don't think it's enough to basically
say everybody else just going to have
to get used to it,
live with it because that is a recipe
for not only increasing inequality,
but what inequality does to social
cohesion to democratic institutions.
Uh,
so I think it's one of the most serious
questions we have to figure out how to
answer. Now, you know, there
are some obvious quick answers,
like you have subsidized employment
for people in certain areas,
or at least they have something
to do all day, every day. Um,
you try to figure out how you create
incentives for companies to keep people
employed instead of making
them unemployed. You know,
the German system where you're,
the government basically
subsidizes you to avoid layoffs,
but then you gotta figure out
what to do with people. I mean,
there are no easy answers and given
the intellectual brainpower in here,
uh,
the United States may be getting to this
sooner than other parts of the world.
Everybody is going to get to it.
So,
I mean right now the Chinese are trying
to figure out how they continue taking
tens of millions of
people out of rural areas,
bringing them to urban areas and putting
them to work when wages are gonna rise,
when their economic advantage then maybe
diminished. So this is a huge social,
political, economic issue. And if you've
got any thoughts, I'd love to hear them.
Let's have a quick question over here.
Sicker essentially continents
and honor to have you here.
I saw you on the daily show recently where
a John Stewart preemptively announced
your candidacy for.
Okay.
No,
I took my daughter about six years ago
to the Democratic primaries to vote for
you in the face.
She would be interested.
She above 82. She's old enough to
vote. That is she, she came to be with.
I love that. Um, how do you, I mean
I, I thought you handled it quite,
but um, how are you going to handle when
there's so many people who are obviously
interested in having you,
uh, in this next election?
Thank you. Well, John
Stewart was a lot of it.
[inaudible]
and, and I love the story of taking your
daughter. We always took Chelsea to vote.
I mean,
really,
I think every 18 year old should be
automatically registered to vote upon
turning 18.
I think we need to get,
um,
this is a very personal decision for me.
Um,
and I don't take it at all lightly.
I'm sort of feeling my way
through it and toward it. Uh,
I,
I think we face some very
serious hard choices as a nation.
And I have no illusions about what a
president alone can do because it's a
necessary to bring the congress to bring
the private sector to get people from
all walks of life involve.
But I think we're at a real juncture.
Uh,
and I'm well aware that I
have a lot of experience.
I've seen the presidency up
close now over 20 years. Uh,
both because of my husband and,
and also I worked closely with George W.
Bush after nine 11 because I was a senator
from New York and we had to rebuild,
you know, lower Manhattan and then
obviously working closely and becoming a,
not just a partner but a
friend of President Obama. Um,
so I am going to take my time because I
know that once I decide if I am going to
run,
it's nonstop and the campaigns are even
more demanding than they were four years
ago. Um, and so,
I mean I've talked with people in the
Obama campaign and they basically say,
you know,
2012 was so much more
advanced technologically and
in voters in terms of voter
outreach,
then 2008 and we don't even know
what's going to be required in 2016.
And I'm sure you know a lot of you because
of what you work on and bent and the
light will be part of that.
So I want to be sure that it's the right
decision for me and that I will not
just, I say in the book,
you shouldn't ask somebody,
in my opinion whether they're going
to run or if they think they can win.
Those are the easy questions and
most people run for president,
no matter what you think, think they
can win or they wouldn't do it. Um,
but really what's your vision for
America and can you lead us there?
And I think that's going to require,
and it goes to the great question that
was asked over here that's going to
require some really careful analysis
and agenda setting because you,
in my opinion, whoever runs,
and certainly if I were to run,
I would want to run on a specific and
agenda as possible because I don't want
there to be any illusions. You know,
we're, we don't have time for people to,
you know,
just think in very general terms because
we have to get a consensus coming out
of this next election about what we're
going to do to solve these problems and
hopefully bring some people
into the congress on both
sides of the aisle who are
willing to compromise and
make those tough calls.
So I'm thinking about it and I hope
you'll say hello to your daughter for me.
Yes.
So Secretary Clinton,
we have a way,
we have a way of asking
during the audience what the
most important question is.
And when you became first lady,
you're name was determined by
the tradition of first lady Tru,
Tru and Googlers want to
know the following question.
They want to know the name of President
Clinton in a scenario where there's
another president,
clinic,
Googlers have indicated that there are two
choices.
The first one is bill.
Okay.
So it would be MS president and bill,
which would have a certain,
yeah,
gender equality,
you know Mr. Clinton and the first lady.
And the second one is first latee
Google. Google does things by,
by consensus. And by votes.
So we're going to
determine this for you now.
So I need a sign of hands,
like all those are your two choices.
She should call him bill.
Okay.
She should call him first.
Laddie the decision is made.
We're announcing it today. Mrs Button.
He's going to be called first lady.
Would you like to respond? Oh, this not,
okay, good. Eric. Oh,
I have to say bill, I
would've voted for bill. Yeah,
I, you know, I, I, there was one
choice that I'm more partial to,
not that this is a hypothetical.
Okay.
And that's first mate.
I kind of liked her first day,
Miss Glynn and first mate, come
on it. We were better than that.
Well, we have to see, I
think you can see first place
we're going to have a book signing after
this in Tunis. I think you can see in,
in Secretary Clinton's, Senator
Clinton, first lady Clinton,
a person of enormous impact on our world.
Somebody who has spent her entire life
with his prodigious mind trying to serve
us. I'm, I'm proud to be your friend and
I admire everything that you've done.
And I know people in this audience feel
the same way. Thank you all so very much.
Right.